[Music]
kak life doesn't get better than this
we've put the past behind
us we have Molly to think about
now what a bonny we can I made her a
bicycle oh what a lovely
thought she is a lot like you see you
later mom can we go over there
[Music]
you've got everything you want right
here you can't make me stay
here she's left the
island what is
that
M the truck's taking chickens to some
kind of farm well hey that doesn't look
so
bad oh that looks so
bad who knows what horror m is dealing
with in
there
huh come on let's
play
y there's something strange about this
place
behold the
dawn of the
Nugget last time we broke out of a
chicken farm well this time
we're breaking
in it's an impossible
mission they're going to turn everyone
into nuggets find those
chickens hang on
Fowler oh there go the
G are you sure you're ready for this I
was hatched ready
Dad we can do this
[Music]
yes